von ed kabel wo ist der verteiler
saniert bist du einfach dass wir kommen
sofort hier auch was auf mich ein punkt
drauf damit nichts kaputt macht man ist
ja witzig irgendwo aber sicher kurz
meine sachen direkt auf wo ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass es so weit geht dass
tnt natürlich macht das alles kaputt ich
mir gar nicht bewusst wie man hier in
meinem bett schlafen
danke danke
ich will auch sagen das ist das ende der
fall drücken gleichzeitig mit dem
schlafen auch die feuerwehren oder
erfolgen würde ich sagen
schlaf gut bis zur nächsten folge und
wenn es euch gefallen hat ein schöner
abschluss hier aber für die airline
nicht dann gibt auch eine positive tun
und dadurch sagen bis zur nächsten folge
ciao so hallo ihr lieben freuen und
herzlich willkommen zurück bei der today
show mit den rund um gespielt letzte
folge war sehr witzig fand ich sehr
liegt noch nicht im bett
ich wollte doch jetzt aufräumen wollte
er schlafen gehen
ach komm geh weg das jetzt auf sonst ins
bett gegangen
umsonst nicht nur kostenlos ich brauche
noch kisten indirekt also ist der aufbau
so und hält dich mal aufgeräumt und
alles wieder in kisten einsortieren habe
ich an
ja wer sonst bitte hab ich doch was auch
wieder ein schild hing immer wieder
darüber gemacht
die bezeichnung was da rein kommt mit
dem schönen bilderrahmen wie das teil
heißt comdirect einen schein
bilderrahmen irgendwie das war alles
eine dein lagerraum alles explodieren
lassen
ich würd sei dass die tracht oder das
gibt drache verdiente rache müsste man
gleich übertreiben luca ihn müssen wir
gleich über drei berge
was hat druckplatte da hingelegt die
wenn dann einen eine 1 10 blöcke von
deinem fand einen sachen entfernt
explodiert das heißt nicht zerstört das
minus aber angefangen von daher ist mir
egal
er hat mich geschlagen habe kann ich ihn
auf den boden bringen und totschlag was
ich alles
er hat mich provoziert jetzt kann ich
auch töten genauso kräftig mit unserer
gesellschaft vergleichen den gut
erkennen
ich hab's alles ich hatte kein grund zu
beleidigen
doch alles ich hab alles aufgeräumt ich
brauche noch mehr erde
dass das stimmt nicht mehr mein meinen
rahmen da wieder angemacht und alles was
oben das muster wieder ordentlich
zusammengebaut oben
egal da soll jetzt eine erste seinem
boot mein wohnzimmer passt da gut hin an
dieser stelle die bäume gepflanzt wird
groß es ist nur ein und er ist auch groß
genug e mails schreiben an die
kommentare ob er den us beleidigen die
reaktion zu viel findet oder ob es
angebracht findet und schreiben die
kommentare dass mein haus wunder
wunderschönes es ist zwar noch ein haus
aber sind drei bäume weiße räume sind
immerhin schöner arzt 2 und 5 und 8
schöner als in das einmal aus
ein kleiner laden kommt noch ein kleiner
raum hin so jetzt kommen wir noch andere
schwester nach der macht jetzt das was
über den kommentare geschrieben wurde
hey brauchbarkeit voran und nimmt die nt
und die zukunft und schlug in der die
ganze zeit all dein haus mein haus war
nicht so
simon macht ordentlich erledigt
beurteilung ist aufgeräumt hat macht ist
nicht mein problem macht ordentlich was
nicht
wo sind meine sache ich verstehe dich
gratis versteht fast gar nichts wäre ein
bürgerentscheid nicht automatisch
regulierung stellen stellt der mich
unter benítez in lauter bin darüber
steuert automatische regulierung immer
ihnen das aus weil lautsprecher für geht
auf diese verbindung symbol geht auf
lautsprecher ja und nimmt den haken raus
bei dieser einstellung automatisch
anpassen und stellte ein tor habe ich
weglaufen wir könnten noch mehr bringen
also die verbindung ist man oft schlecht
also ist bei mir so dumpf und kacke egal
sagt beide was geht es bei den noch
nicht
also ihr habt euch bei mir beide normal
an ganz komisch einer frechen tannenbaum
weil dingsbums habe ich jetzt gerade
sagt gerade alle pflanzen wo sie meine
sachen habe ich gefragt ich heiße ich
brauche noch mehr knochen sachen denn
alle die hier waren drei kisten die
jetzt weg sind ich habe eine menge
aufgenommen hat was aufgenommen hat
alles erlebt hat überhaupt nichts mit
man übrigens gar nichts ich habe keine
alten keine männersache warte so was
fehlt denn jetzt überhaupt erst auf als
er war wandten drei weitere kisten drei
weitere doppel kisten waren da zu sagen
dass alles in ordnung also ich hab alle
sachen die ich aufgenommen her ihr
gewicht hätte es als aufgabe schon
gedacht dass es nicht machst nicht mal
versucht habe ich hab's versucht aber
wenn du hier das wenn das holz nicht
hier ist und alles was kann ich dafür
wenn das holz nicht da soll ich jetzt
mir selber sachen suchen
davon sind bis 22 ja absolut ich war
unnötig
in der dich dass du mir so ich verstehe
warum holt er seine gefühle verletzt ich
sagte ja es gab bei mir unten
das alles explodiert okay das ist jetzt
natürlich witzlos wenn du es einfach
selber machst ja es geht dann keinen
anderen weg mehr wird es lange genug
zeit des obst muss natürlich auch immer
passiert
den affront nicht überstülpen der forst
zu treten
scheiße
goalie brent cohen ist tot
gut genug
ihr habt einfach alles einfach nur krank
kommt dass du ruhig das heißt nichts
gutes von apple-chef hausbau leiste und
fraktion rückt jetzt mein haus war
vorhin schatten alle interessierte sorgt
für eure krieg und mein haus weiterhin
steht mein haus auf ein bisschen
demoliert ist kann ich noch nicht war
nichts mehr hört auch nur zu man kann es
noch finder hat man sich selbst gemacht
das war okay vielleicht letzte chance
genutzt hier irgendwas zu bauen
ich bin ganz aus dem beruf raus gegangen
das wird somit die grösste rache geben
dies gibt ist mir scheißegal diesem game
und mache oder nicht ich bin sogar
gebannt vom server ich werde einfach den
us komplettes haus in die luft sprengt
sei es wenn ich wenn es gerade nicht
aufnahme ist oder wenn aufnahme ist ich
habe bei ihm ein tnt gesetzt und habe
seinen räumen die luft gesprengt und er
hat sogar angefangen hat bei mir in
tente hingesetzt das hätte bei mir auch
einiges in die luft gesprengt
natürlich keine kisten aber das war
nicht meine absicht ich hätte mit ihm
reden können und war dabei die sachen
wieder ein zu sortieren und da waren die
template ich hätte es ihm sogar
zurückgegeben sache ist allerdings nur
als auf einmal die nah bei mir ist und
total witzlos ihm die 20 tnt dahin setzt
mich anzündet mich dreimal
hintereinander tötet mich band alle
sachen von mir zerstört mein komplettes
haus ist im arsch ich hab einfach gar
nichts mehr
meine level sind weg alles ist weg ich
hab den dadurch geflogen meine ganzen
auch weg also das war sehr sehr unklug
und ich zweifel gerade wirklich an
den als intellektualität von so einer
tat vor allem ich dann auch noch zu
bannen
also nicht mehr mit den konsequenzen zu
rechnen ich bin immer noch gebannt das
heißt ich mache ihn jetzt sogar es
passiert ich war ja auch kunstwerke ihr
redet ja über ewigen sowie arena sa an
also jetzt ist ja alles so kaputt so
also von oben geht es eigentlich ja es
ist nicht viel kaputt das bei dir habe
ich auch wieder so halbwegs aufgebaut
bei mir sieht toll aus hat auch etwas
neues so allerdings hier unten falls ich
sollte ich gesehen habt ihr ja ja sieht
nicht so schön aus allem ein item sind
weg nix ich hab gar nichts mehr außer
man erinnert ist und deswegen sind wir
ja schon creative mode und ja leute ich
hab den lagerraum bisschen vergrössern
ist so schön danke den sache erstmal wie
das hier nach alles abgelaufen ist wie
wir das nach ich hatte lust habt also
ich hab mir meine aufnahme gerade
gestoppt das habt ihr gesehen möchte
dass hinten dran packe wo ich dann
gebannt wurde von den und dann hab ich
ja das ist eine große racheaktion geben
und blauen klub und dann bin ich halt
nicht mehr welchen das geld gegangen und
dann
hab ich erstmal noch ich habe erst mal
fünf minuten probiert hier draufzukommen
hat aber nicht hingekriegt gebannt wurde
wenn ein skype gegangen bin dezent
ausgelastet was mit einem formidablen
piepton unterlegt wurde von den können
bei denen aufnahme sehen hören und
danach haben uns dann darüber geredet
haben gesagt dass wir das ganze jetzt
hier sagt du ich möchte sich sein game
show wobei es liegt alles an sie mal
hört alles zerstört ein keil zwischen
uns getrieben
gestern also passiert gleich in die luft
gesprengt
also wir hatten uns wirklich gedacht
dass wir das ganze jetzt schon 70 voll
gemacht haben und das ist ja jetzt nicht
einfach so 70 folgen sondern das waren
70 folgen aber nicht 140 und 160 tage
mit ein paar pausen dazwischen 360 tage
mit reinziehen das sind fünf monate dann
und stellen mehr als vier das ist sehr
sehr lange für ein projekt etwas hoch
lag und es ist jetzt auch kein normales
together wo man einfach so zeit findet
den lass uns noch ganz kurz wir bauen
das erst mal kurz alles auf und dann zum
letzten tag ein projekt wo man sie haben
sich mal einfach so trifft und dann ein
bisschen was aufnimmt sondern es ist
natürlich man muss dann gäste wohl man
muss alles mögliche machen sondern muss
natürlich eine menge arbeit mit
verbunden
und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht dass
wir im teilnehmerfeld
deswegen hat das geändert allein ich
direkt ganz kurz zu ändern wir haben
dann gedacht dass wir das ganze projekt
dann jetzt einfach damit wenn werden
eine riesige explosion wird das ganze zu
ende führen wir ich hätte allgemein
gedacht dass wir das bei 100 vollen
wenden weil auch einfach die lust ein
bisschen weg ist so lange immer das
gleiche weil er oft schon gesehen ich
habe immer wieder neues haus angefangen
zu bauen weil es einfach ein bisschen
langweilig wurde
ich hoffe einfach ihre damit
einverständnis wird natürlich weitere
sachen geben wie zum beispiel manger
games oder trabi
irgendwie sowas wo ihr den er und nicht
zusammen sehen könnt möchte ich muss
sagen ja ich bin als gast hinzugekommen
und jetzt bin ich als epischer gast der
letzten finalen folge in die geschichte
der tv-show eingang besser als wenn ich
offen bin das war mir sehr wichtig so
kaputt gemacht wurde hatte man
explodiert japanischen das ganze theater
nicht meine wunderschöne braut wird die
nacht viel machen gab er alte gmbh ein
wunderschönes es hätte so schön werden
können mache bitte hier
time city oder wie rainer wir müssen das
noch alles zu kämpfen und so hin bauen
ein haus steht noch der steht noch steht
noch steht noch zur warte was steht
jetzt hier noch
steht doch halb mein haus hat überlebt
in der mitte stehen doch das muss auch
stehen bleibt das bleibt drauf vor dem
winter wieder gerade der höhe
ja und es wird und wahrscheinlich auch
22 apps zum download geben einmal die
zerstörte hier die and web und ein bald
die map auf der noch alles drauf ist
bevor mein haus zach musste ein neuer so
dass man alles als verein nicht als paar
vor der aufnahme war das alles nicht
geplant dass das hier so enden wird
aber schon in der endabnahme gesagt in
der produkt an das heißt es war nicht
wie abgesprochen so alles auf einmal so
passiert als dass tnt da und mach' ich
mir gedacht da konnte ich und dann war
das vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel das
haben wir dann auch in dem moment
gedacht habe ich nicht mit gerechnet
dass das alles auf sein auf seinen
keller da und alles so heftig über geht
und dass die ganzen teams verschwinden
habe ich auch total verdrängt haben
existiert noch oder heute ist noch was
hinten lange aber wer sich dass dieses
von kef alles mache ich mit das mache
ich dann kaputt das haus von kev und ist
dann alles irgendwie blöd gelaufen muss
man zu sagen hier ist der komplette
laufen bei mir alle komplette server
egal wo ich eine fackel hinsetze
verschwinden die blöcke steht auch noch
so ein bisschen ist das haus war
es gebe hier dass die pyramide steht
noch auf skates haus steht noch das geht
ja nie und steht auch noch der vom start
weg springt er bei mir steht das noch
bei mir steht kämpft auch noch dicht ist
ja aber nur so halb oder warte ich mach
dein ripper hin dass noch viel cooler
nein kein ritter ritter so laut leute
auf jeden fall bitte nicht traurig sein
das war ein schönes projekt das bald
ändert tracht nochmal länder treffen bis
1 übersteht ist noch das haus von space
world germany stehen wir mal sagen hey
dein haus steht noch du bist cool ich
finds geld sollte auch verdient
jetzt sollte auch einfach stehen bleiben
aber immer gesagt braucht spielpraxis
oder das reicht auch ein stopp seine
inneneinrichtung reden auf ihrem eine
schöne beschauliche sitzt aber hier ist
wenn schon denn schon
okay das war's jetzt geld aus das hier
war dann das erste cover show ok also
ich bin ich freue mich ich bin stolz
darauf mit hier dabei sein zu dürfen
ich hätte der nächsten folge diesmal
also welche nächste gast gewesen welt
zufällig und nicht mehr geklappt oder
also wahlleute hatten einfach nicht also
wir hatten noch geplant leute einzuladen
wie zur uniqa dgh die luke place wollten
wir alle noch einladen kann ich aber im
auch schon dran der wir auch eigentlich
schon forum gespielt da gewesen
jetzt wird es auch nichts mehr ein paar
lustige gestern bei hoffentlich auch ein
bisschen spaß an sehr langes projekt
offen ja das war mir seit dem sommer
letzten jahren gefahren und dann war es
aber still war es dann also der mit ihr
will hier mit so vielen schwarz mit xxl
folge am ende sogar 5 20 minuten oder so
ist ja wenn es euch gefallen dann könnt
ihr ein daumen hoch geben und dann sehen
wir uns beim ablegen des leute dann
würde ich einfach sagen sehen wir unsere
fräst aber wahrscheinlich dass babys
oder bei einem pilotprojekt damit
einfach sagen danke euch arbeiten durfte
war auf jeden fall lustig als ein
bisschen das gefühl ich bin okay
zwischen die fronten geraten
lena ja grad und zerstören hast du bot
media steht noch das geht nicht
mein baum steht auch noch aus
habt ihr ein thema dsl hardware stecken
ja nicht der wille dass sie nun in ruhe
den ausdruck der einmal ändert wegen
einer trading
wie sieht er aus musst du in die studios
sind ja aber ich habe doch gibson sonst
nicht hat sich als normal aber du kannst
du ein befehl eingeben / noch einmal ran
geht es wahrscheinlich nicht
also hier herrscht wirklich die
komplette apokalypse unterschied das
motto auf hop oder ritter schied die gas
ab das hier witzig es ist hier ich mache
ich die rechte ist geschafft noch ein
paar ich hoffe ein paar contra hier sind
als aussieht wechseln
ja das sieht toll aus der baum brennt du
wirklich das hast du so gemacht
ja das sieht schön aus bevor wir es hier
alles noch weiter ausartet downloadlink
der map findet in der beschreibung wenn
ihr die kaputte welt noch haben wollte
und ansonsten die welt vor simon steht
auch einer beschreibung teppich dabei
auf der richtige da stand in der mitte
also ja alles zu besprechen
danke an alle radler übrigens für die
ganzen tagen auch jonas 16 servern zeit
gesponsert und viele zuschauer ein
bis zum nächsten mal machst